All right, it looks like we're live.
End of week nine.
Almost done.
Sad to think I only have
a week left with you all.
All right.
So, for today
I asked you to read the MapReduce paper
and we're going to be devoting all of
today
and uh some of next time to be talking
about MapReduce. I actually allocated
two days for this in our schedule
uh because there's a lot to say.
But, um we might end up using some of
next Tuesday to talk about something
else. We'll see.
In the meantime, though
uh let's get started with today.
So, on the schedule today
we're going to be talking about
online versus offline systems
and
raw
and derived data.
And then we're going to get into talking
about MapReduce.
And a lot of this will be an extended
example.
Where we're going to talk about
computing an inverted index
from what's called a forward index.
Okay, so before we jump into talking
about MapReduce, uh let's set the stage
a little bit uh uh by talking about this
uh about what MapReduce is exactly.
So, up until now
we've been talking a whole lot about
systems to which you make requests
and you receive responses. So
the key-value store that you've been
implementing works that way.
Uh Dynamo works that way. Web servers
work that way.
Databases work that way.
Caching layers sitting in front of
databases work that way. So,
all those different kinds of systems,
you can lump them together under
the term
online systems.
Also known as
services.
So, examples include things like like we
said, key-value stores
um
web servers
databases
caches
etc.
So, the characteristic that these
systems share
is that they wait for requests to arrive
from clients
and then try to handle them quickly.
So, low latency is really important in
these kinds of systems. Remember what
low latency is. So, low latency is time
between
when you make a request and when you get
a response. So, that's really important.
Availability.
Every request receives a response.
Usually also important.
So
low latency and availability are often
prioritized.
Maybe not always. Like it depends on the
design of the system. But, um but that's
typical for these kinds of systems. So,
Dynamo which was the last paper we read
is a classic example of something that
falls into this category.
Reading the MapReduce paper after
reading the Dynamo paper
might have
been a bit of a a radical shift for some
of you because
MapReduce does not fall into this
category.
This is not the only way of building
systems.
There are also systems that take in a
huge amount of data
do something to process it
and then produce output data. And this
might take quite a while.
It might take a few minutes. It might
take a few hours. It might take a few
days even.
So, this would be a different category
systems and we call these
offline systems.
Or batch processing systems.
And MapReduce
is a classic example
of one of these systems. So, the main
concern with these kinds of systems is
not having low latency.
The main concern with these kinds of
systems is having high throughput.
So, the goal here is to process lots of
data
and high throughput is the priority.
So, the more data that you can process
at a time, the faster that you can
crunch through a huge input data set,
which is the goal with these systems.
So, MapReduce falls into this category.
So, although So, MapReduce is this is
classic work from Google from 2004. And
although Google obviously runs a lot of
online systems, too
under the hood
the data that those systems are serving
up, which could be things like search
results or videos or so on
it was most likely the result of some
very large-scale
offline
data processing job done by an offline
system
which would at Google probably either be
MapReduce or one of MapReduce's
successors.
So
this might feel a little bit weird,
right? To be talking about this after
we've spent almost the whole quarter
talking about online systems and
responding to requests quickly. Um but
these are a very important class of
systems.
So, MapReduce is now
uh
over 15 years old. It's not the shiny
new technology that it once was, but
it's still worth studying and
understanding
uh because it helps us see why and how
uh this kind of large-scale batch
processing of data is important and
useful. So, we're going to spend some
time talking about it.
Um by the way, you might ask
"Well, do all systems that we care about
fall into one of these two categories of
online systems or offline systems?" So
as so often
there's
the such a thing as a hybrid between the
two.
And this is a fairly new area uh and we
don't necessarily have great terminology
for it. But, um some people are
converging on using the term streaming
systems
uh to talk about a class of system that
kind of is somewhere in between online
and offline systems.
In the sense that
it has to process a lot of data
but
it also wants to be able to respond
quickly to changes.
So, with something like MapReduce
you get a whole bunch of data all at
once and then you process it. With a
streaming system
you might be getting a whole lot of
data, but you might be getting it over
time. And you might want to
incrementally process the data as you
get it without having to redo all the
work when you get one new piece of data.
So, this space of streaming systems is
is fairly new and has been emerging over
the last uh
eight or 10 years.
Um we aren't going to be spending a
whole lot of time talking about
streaming systems. Uh but if you're
interested in this um
uh there's a great blog post written by
Jamie Brandon, which I would suggest you
look up
uh which sort of tries to sketch out the
space of streaming systems. Uh which um
I think if you just Google for streaming
systems Jamie Brandon, then you might
find it. And I'll try to find a link and
and paste it later. And he tried kind of
tries to sketch out uh an overview of
the space of streaming systems.
Uh
but you can can think of this as sort of
a hybrid of online and offline.
That said, today we're going to be
talking about MapReduce, a classic
offline system.
Okay, so
to set the stage for
why you want something like MapReduce,
we can kind of turn back a little bit to
what we were talking about last time
when we were discussing sharding.
So
when we talked about sharding last time,
we were only talking about the notion of
of splitting up a a data set that
consisted of something like key-value
pairs, right? Like Dynamo does. So, last
time
we talked about you know, maybe you want
to have some different shards and maybe,
you know, this shard over here has, you
know, these key-value pairs and this one
over here has these key-value pairs.
But
we didn't talk about anything more
sophisticated than just this data model
model that consists of a a whole bunch
of key-value pairs.
So, it was a very simple data model.
That's what a database person would say.
The data model here was very simple.
But
what if you had some more sophisticated
data model? Let's say you had, for
instance, something like a a a
a relational database that had a whole
bunch of different tables.
If you had that, then the question of
how to shard the data becomes a lot more
subtle, right? What data do you store
next to what data?
And that gets really complicated as soon
as the data model gets more
sophisticated. With this
the question of sharding is still, you
know, interesting, but you don't have to
worry about things like, you know, does
this key-value pair depend on this other
key-value pair? Does this one depend on
this one? And then if I update this one,
does this one on the other shard also
have to be updated? You don't have to
worry about any of that stuff if it's
just this very simple data model of
key-value pairs. As soon as you have a
more sophisticated data model, you have
to worry about stuff like uh how to how
to shard data in a way that will make
your queries efficient.
So let's take something like like
Facebook as an example. So
users accessing the site
might have very different access
patterns than, let's say, somebody who's
a data scientist at Facebook who's
trying to analyze how people use
Facebook. So, if you're a user accessing
the site, you might want to see
something like for example
the updates of everybody who you're
friends with, right? You want to see all
of your friends' updates.
Uh the data scientist might be making a
totally different kind of query, right?
Like they might want to see, "Oh, I want
to see all of the updates of everybody
who's in a certain age range, right? And
who's interested in, you know, such and
such a topic, right?"
So
those are different kinds of queries
that have a different kind of shape,
right?
And that should
kind of make you wonder, how should the
data be sharded in such a way that it's
going to be most efficient for those
different kinds of queries to be
supported?
For the typical user using the site,
they're going to kind of want the data
to be sliced and diced one way. And for
the data scientist who's doing this kind
of entirely different kind of query,
they're going to want the data to be
sliced and diced a different way,
differently organized. The same data,
but organized in a different way. Why is
it organized in a different way? Because
the queries that they're making are
shaped really differently. So
ultimately, the way that this works is
they'll want to optimize for the regular
user of the site, right? They want those
users to be able to access the site
quickly.
Um so, but instead of having the data
scientists always be sad, right? Because
their queries are always slow
what they might do is have a redundant,
but differently organized copy of the
data for the data scientists to work
with.
So
same underlying data, different
representations.
In the MapReduce paper, they have names
for these different representations of
data. Does anybody remember what they
are?
So, if you want, go back and look at the
paper. This comes up fairly early in the
paper.
Like kind of right in the introduction.
Intermediate key-value pairs. Okay, so
this is something that's part of
carrying out a MapReduce job. But my
question is more like
what are the names for these different
representations of data that we're
talking about? Like, for example
in the Facebook example, there's the way
that the data organized that might be
organized for users to see, like the
actual flow of posts as they're
happening, and then the kind of queries
that the data scientist might like to
do, which are more like getting
aggregate information. So, in the
MapReduce paper and right in the first
paragraph of the paper, they call these
raw data
and derived data.
So, raw data is like the authoritative
version
in some sense.
New data comes in
and it goes into some form of raw data
storage.
Derived data is the result of taking
some existing data
and processing it somehow.
So, either taking raw data and
processing it or taking some other
derived data and processing it. So, you
can have raw data
So, there's input
which becomes raw data
which can become derived data.
And then derived data could also become
derived data.
So, the easiest way that I can think of
to describe MapReduce is to say
MapReduce is a tool for computing
derived data.
Does anybody remember what the first
example it is that they give in the
MapReduce paper of derived data?
Yeah, that's right. Inverted indices.
So, yeah, like in sentence one of the
paper, they talk about an inverted
index. So, I think this term is a little
confusing. So, let's go over it.
Okay, so
obviously, if you're Google, you care a
lot about search.
A search engine is trying to index
everything on the web, right? Or as much
of it as it can get to.
So, you have a a web crawler that goes
out and gets a bunch of documents.
And so
you end up with a list of documents.
Uh and let's say a list of words that
are in each document. So maybe it's
something like this.
Maybe document two is
etc.
So this is what is sometimes called a
forward index.
So this might be the data structure that
gets built
as
you crawl the web.
And this is good for
putting data into quickly, right? As
you're going around and crawling the web
uh and trying to collect data that
you're going to use for your search
engine, right?
But is this data format good for things
like doing queries? Like let's say I
want you to give me all the documents
that have the word dog in them.
Is this kind of a format good for that
kind of a query?
No.
That would be really, really slow if
this were how your data were organized.
So you don't organize it this way or at
least you don't only organize it this
way. Instead you build what's called an
inverted index.
So in the inverted index
it's an inversion of the forward index.
So instead of having a list of documents
and then for every document a list of
words that are in that document instead
the inverted index is a list of words.
And then for every word the list of
documents that it's in.
So we might have the and it's in
document one and document two.
And so on.
So now we have a data structure that
supports fast looking up by word.
There's no more information in this
inverted index than there was in the
forward index before.
It's just that so we could have done
those kinds of lookups in this one. It's
just that it would have been really
slow.
This organization of the data is better
for a query that lets you look things up
by what words are in the document.
And that's it. That's all an inverted
index is.
Okay.
So
how would you write a program to turn
the forward index into the inverted
index? And this is not a distributed
systems question yet. So
forget replication, forget partitioning,
forget fault tolerance, all that stuff
we've spent eight weeks on. Forget it.
How would you write an algorithm to turn
the forward index into the inverted
index?
What do you think?
Okay, so the suggestion in chat is a
create a hash table
whose keys are words and values are an
array of document IDs. Okay, yeah,
that's what this is. I mean I don't know
if it has to be a hash table. It's a
table for sure. It's a dictionary of
some kind. And yeah, the keys are words
and the the the values are are document
IDs. But how would you do it? What would
be the algorithm for doing it if I
handed you this forward index?
Well, okay, so here's one thing we could
do.
We could take the forward index.
Uh we could loop over all the documents.
So we could say something like for each
document
D
and then for every that every document
there's all these words, right? So then
you have to loop over the words.
For each word
we're going to say emit this pair
of the word
and the document.
So this could be one phase of the
computation, right? So from this you
would get a bunch of pairs that might
look like
the
is part of doc one.
Quick
And so on. And then you might get the
is part of doc two. Dog is part of doc
two.
And so on.
So this is what you'd get as output from
this first step up here.
And then what do you do with that?
Reduce it. Yeah. So how do you reduce
it? Well
if this is what we have but this is what
we want
well we really want these
pairs that have the same word to be
combined, right? We really want
uh
only one pair for every unique word,
right? So we really want something more
like
the
and then we want a list here of doc one
and doc two.
And then that's
the first row of our inverted index.
So we want this and then we want another
step where we're going to combine the
documents in a list
for every unique word.
So to summarize
if you're starting with the forward
index then we're going to loop over all
the documents in the forward index.
That's this first line here.
And then
for each document you're going to loop
over every word in it
and you're going to emit this pair
of of the word and the document ID.
So we've now got a list
of key value pairs essentially with some
repeated keys, right?
And so now all there is to do
is to make it so all the keys are unique
and squash down their values to a list
of values.
And then we have this inverted index.
So I think this name inverted index is
sometimes a little bit confusing because
it's really just an index like you would
see in the back of a book.
It's a list of words.
And for every every word there's a list
of places where that word occurs. So in
the back of a book it might be page
numbers or something like that.
Uh
but it's very much like what we would be
used to seeing for the index in the back
of a book. And we normally don't call
that an inverted index, right? We
normally just call it an index.
But people who make search engines call
it an inverted index because for them
it's an inversion of the forward index
which is the data that gets collected
from the um from the web crawl.
Okay.
So would you say that this process of
creating the inverted index from the
forward index, would you say that this
is particularly complicated
conceptually?
When you leave aside all that stuff that
I said to leave out, replication and
fault tolerance and partitioning and
even concerns of efficiency, if you
leave all that stuff out,
would you say that the algorithm for
creating this inverted index is
particularly conceptually complicated?
Not really. Right, yeah.
I wouldn't.
It's pretty straightforward. I'm sure
any of you could write the code to do it
with no sweat.
So, why am I even talking about this?
Why is this even a topic of discussion
in a distributed systems class? What do
you think?
Right, if you have a really really
really large data set, if you're trying
to do this at large scale,
this becomes a distributed systems
problem. All of a sudden,
you have to think about things like
fault tolerance. You have to think about
things like partitioning. You have to
think about the stuff that this course
is about as soon as you try to do this
stuff at large scale.
So, the insight of MapReduce was that
the authors, as well as well as a whole
lot of other people,
they observed that a lot of the
computations that they wanted to do were
very conceptually simple like this.
So,
it's the kind of code that somebody
could write very straightforwardly.
But, because they had to do it on a huge
amounts of data
in a distributed fashion, the simplicity
of the computations that they wanted to
do was obscured by all of the code that
had to handle all of the distributed
systems stuff. So, they thought,
"Wouldn't it be nice if there was a
framework that would allow people to
write these conceptually simple
algorithms like this, and then plug them
into a system that hides all of that
distributed system stuff and takes care
of it all automatically for them?" And
that's exactly what MapReduce is.
So, MapReduce is a framework that lets
you plug in the code for the
conceptually simple computation that you
want to do,
which hopefully won't be very much code,
right?
And then we'll take care of distributing
that computation over a whole bunch of
machines for you.
So, let's say that our forward index is
really really big, right? Too big to fit
on one machine.
So, maybe some of the rows of this
forward index are on one machine,
and some are on another machine, and
some are on a third machine, and so on.
And let's also suppose that this
finished inverted index is also too big
to fit on one machine. And that's normal
for a MapReduce computation. That's par
for the course for a MapReduce
computation.
So, what do you do? Let's say that
you're a machine and you have only one
part
of the forward index. Let's say that you
just have this one row
on your machine.
That would be kind of an extreme case,
but let's say that this one document is
really really really really enormous
just for the just for the sake of
discussion. So, let's say that you just
have this one row of the forward index,
and you're a machine, you're tasked with
with running your part of this
algorithm.
What do you do? How do you proceed?
Okay, the suggestion you tried is
partition each word to an individual
worker thread.
Hmm.
Okay.
I think you're on the right track,
although that might be a little bit
overkill, right? If you're a machine and
you you're one machine, you have one
document to process. I guess the
question I'm asking is
what part of this code do you run that I
wrote down here? Well,
if we look at the inner
part of this loop, right? This right
here.
That doesn't change for you, right?
You've got a document, and now for every
word in that document, you can emit one
of these pairs, right?
So, you can just go ahead and compute
your
word document pairs for the part of the
input that you're responsible for,
whether it's, you know, one document or
maybe a handful of documents or
whatever.
You can compute that for whichever
documents that you have.
Your neighbors, the other machines, can
compute theirs for whatever part of the
input that they have.
So, in other words,
the outer loop here
could be done in parallel
for all the documents.
Is there any dependency between the
different iterations of this loop?
Like, do we care about what order they
run in, the different iterations of this
for each document loop here?
Let's say I'm another machine who's
responsible for this document.
Does what the first machine is doing
with the Let's say this is on on machine
one and this one is on machine two.
Does machine two care at all about what
machine one is doing? Does it affect my
job at all?
Yeah, it shouldn't. Right. Every
document is independent. That's right.
There's no dependency. They're
completely independent.
So,
this
inner loop here can be carried out
by these different machines for the
documents that they're responsible for
totally independently of the other
machines.
So,
these are totally independent.
And this is really nice.
We call computations like this
embarrassingly parallel.
That is,
it's so easy to split up the computation
into independent parallel tasks that it
would be embarrassing not to do it.
There are a lot of things in the world
that are truly hard to parallelize, but
this is not one of them.
So, let's sketch that out. Let's imagine
that every row of this forward index,
that is, every document is on its own
machine.
So, we've got something like this.
Here's M1,
and here's M2,
here's M3,
and we'll just start with three for the
sake of discussion.
So, M1 has
uh
document one,
and it's got
the
quick
brown
fox
etc.
And machine two has something like
another document.
Something like that.
And then maybe machine three has another
document.
And so on. Okay.
So, in this embarrassingly parallel
computation,
every machine
is going to do the same It's going to
run the same function
on its piece of the input, on its piece
of the forward index.
And it's going to do that computation
and then write the results
to its own local memory.
Importantly, no communication between
machines is necess- necessary to do
this.
So,
uh machine one will end up with
something like
the
paired with doc one.
Quick paired with doc one.
Brown.
Again paired with doc one and so on.
Um,
machine two will get
something like this.
Machine three will have
The results of this computation
on each one of these machines
are called intermediate key value pairs.
That's what those are.
So, notice that
when this machine computes this,
it's just doing a local
write to its own memory.
So, this isn't a message being sent to
some other machine or anything like
that. It's just storing the results of
computing these intermediate key value
pairs in its own memory.
And it's important to point out that M1
and M2 and M3 didn't have to communicate
with each other at all to be able to do
that.
Okay.
So, we're part of the way toward
computing our inverted index.
To finish creating the inverted index
now, what do we have to do with the
intermediate key value pairs?
Right. Okay, you have to reduce. But,
what does that mean specifically in the
context of this computation?
Yeah, you have to combine the pairs in a
particular way.
You have to group it in a certain way.
That's right.
So, you want to look at these keys,
right?
And what you want to end up with is
something where
all of the documents that in which the
word the occurs are grouped together,
right? And all the documents in which
quick occurs are grouped together and so
on. That's what you want your inverted
index to look like.
Um, but how are we going to do that,
right? Cuz
our data is spread out among a bunch of
different machines.
So, let's say that we have two machines
for this next phase of the computation.
And I'll call call them R1 and R2.
What is going to be a good way
to put this all this intermediate data
onto these two machines?
As a hint,
we talked about it a little bit last
time when we were talking about
sharding.
Hasher, yeah. So,
one way to get all of these intermediate
key value pairs onto these two machines
is hashing the keys
and then doing mod two of the hash,
right? Cuz we have two machines we have
to split the data up onto.
So, in general, if you have some number
of machines here, like R machines, then
you can take the hash of the keys mod R.
Why do we do that? Well, the happy
outcome
of hashing
by key and then going mod R is that then
you're going to end up with everything
with the same key on the same machine.
So, in this case we would end up with
something like
the
doc one.
That's this one here.
The
doc two. That's this one.
Maybe this one is also responsible for
the key dog.
So, dog was here.
And dog was here.
These other ones just occurred once.
Let's say that these all ended up on
this machine.
Oh, I forgot I.
By the way, if you were doing this for
real, you might uh ignore
words like the
because you wouldn't necessarily care
about those depending on the
application. For something like search,
you probably wouldn't care about the.
You wouldn't care about what are called
stop words. But,
leaving aside things like that,
you would end up with this outcome where
everything that had the same key
ended up on the same machine. If your
approach of sorting these intermediate
key value pairs onto these two machines
for the second phase of the computation,
if you were taking the hash of the key
uh and then doing mod two in this case,
you'd end up with everything with the
same key on the same machine.
And that is exactly what you want,
right?
Because for the next phase of the
computation, all you have to do
is put together the ones that have the
same key. So, in this case,
you want to combine the pairs that have
the same key. So, this would turn into
uh
Maybe I need a different color.
This would turn into
the
would get paired with doc one and doc
two.
And dog
would be paired with doc two
and doc three.
So, R1 and R2 have a pretty easy job.
They just have to combine the pairs that
have the same key.
Interestingly,
a lot of the work of the computation got
done
by
the sorting of the data onto R1 and R2.
So, how did that data get there? How did
the data get onto R1 and R2? Well,
they had to read it from the local disks
of these M1, M2, M3 machines, right?
And this is a little bit difficult
because
like for example,
which machines does R1 have to read
from? Which of these machines is R1
going to have to read from?
All of them. That's right. It's going to
have to read from all of them.
And likewise, R2 is going to have to
read from all of them. In this case, it
didn't happen to have any In this
drawing, I didn't have any from machine
two, but in general,
every one of these machines is going to
have to read from every one
of the machines computing the key value
pairs. So, you have a communication
pattern that looks like this.
So, fortunately, once the data is
actually on R1 and R2, then they can do
their computation independently of each
other, right? So, M1 and M2 and M3 all
commuted computed independently of each
other to begin with. And then once the
data is on R1 and R2, then they can do
their work independently of each other.
But, in the middle, you had this big
transfer of data.
So, this phase right here
is known as a shuffle.
So, I'm going to call this a
communication pattern.
And I use the word communication pattern
rather than computation pattern
uh because in some sense no actual
computation takes place here. It's just
a matter of moving data around, right?
But
this ends up accounting for a huge chunk
of the time that it takes to do these
kinds of computations. So shuffling is
expensive. It requires sending a whole
lot of data over the network.
And it's done for the sole purpose of
getting that data into the right place
in order to do the next phase of
computation on it.
So the good news here is that you can
sometimes play tricks to try to avoid
having to shuffle so much data
um which we can talk about later.
Um
but
in the meantime, let's uh let's see if
we're done computing our inverted index.
Okay, so are we done? Well, basically
um R1 and R2 did their work.
Um I kind of left out the part that R2
did here because these ones uh
we didn't have any words here where they
uh they they appeared in the same
document. But you can imagine this sort
of
doing a rather boring sort of
the massaging of the data to getting it
in the right format.
Okay.
Are we done computing our inverted
index? Well, basically
all that's left to do is for R1 and R2
to write their output somewhere.
And in MapReduce, what they do is they
write it to a distributed file system.
So the output
of this whole process gets written to a
distributed file system
which it in in the MapReduce paper is
called GFS.
So GFS is Google's distributed file
system or it's the distributed file
system that Google used to use.
Um it stands for Google file system.
The name is very creative.
And that's it. Congratulations, you now
know MapReduce. So we just walked
through a typical MapReduce computation.
The part of the computation that takes
place over here on the machines M1, M2,
M3,
this is called the map phase.
Moving the data
from those machines to these machines
is the shuffle phase.
And then the part of the computation
that took place
on the R machines here is known as the
reduce phase.
So the particular example that we looked
at here was creating an inverted index.
But it turns out that this particular
pattern of map phase, shuffle phase,
reduce phase
is common to a lot of computations.
So the only part of this
pattern that was specific to this
particular task at hand
was a couple of little pieces of code.
There was the piece of code that ran on
the map workers
that computed these intermediate
key-value pairs from the raw data.
And there was the little piece of code
that ran on the reduce workers that
computed the output um from the
intermediate key-value pairs that that
appeared on each reduce worker.
Everything else here
is not specific to that particular task.
So in the MapReduce framework you have
to write two little pieces of code
which are known as the map function
which runs on each of these machines.
And the reduce function which runs on
each of these machines.
You have to write those two pieces of
code
and then the rest will be handled for
you by the framework. It will split up
your input onto the map workers which
are what these machines are known as for
the map phase.
It'll put your code on those machines so
that the code can run on the data.
It will handle the shuffling for you so
that the correct intermediate key-value
pairs get put onto these machines which
are known as the reduce workers.
And it will make sure that the output of
the reduce workers ends up
on the distributed file system such as
GFS.
And by the way, everything on GFS gets
replicated. So
you end up uh
actually using twice as much output
storage as the as the output that your
computation produces if you're
replicating everything if your
replication factor is two.
Okay, question in chat. Does GFS allow
for concurrent writes or do the workers
take turns writing to the distributed
file system? I can only imagine that GFS
allows for massively concurrent writes.
Especially because um
these reduce workers could be writing to
distinct files in the file system.
So the output of the
entire MapReduce job doesn't have to be
a single file.
So that's the essence of MapReduce in
one picture.
MapReduce has a popular open-source
clone by the way. Does anybody know what
that's called?
Hadoop. That's right.
Yeah.
And of course
MapReduce depends on the existence of
GFS.
So Hadoop has its own clone of that,
too. So it's called HDFS which stands
for Hadoop distributed file system.
Okay.
So the idea with MapReduce is that you
the programmer have to specify these two
little pieces of code, the map function
and the reduce function.
In our picture over here
the map function is represented by this
that I have boxed in red here.
So this is the map function.
And then this part here where I said
combine the documents in a list for each
unique word
that represents the reduce function.
So with MapReduce, you have to specify
those two things.
And you have to say something about
where the MapReduce framework will find
the input data.
So typically the input data is going to
be stored somewhere on GFS to begin with
or HDFS maybe if you're using Hadoop.
And then the MapReduce framework does
the rest.
And it turns out that a whole lot of
common data processing tasks can fit
into this particular programming model.
So the paper gives a bunch of examples
of that. So it talks about
in addition to this uh
this example that we just looked at.
Um
So we talked about computing an inverted
index.
Uh the paper talks about grep.
In other words, uh
uh
searching for a particular se- searching
for uh documents that match a particular
regular expression.
Um
uh distributed sorting
uh distributed word count
and more.
So these are all computations that can
be expressed in the MapReduce
programming model. You can think of the
the job of the MapReduce framework as
factoring out all the code that's common
to doing all these things in a massive
distributed setting and making it so
that you don't have to manually write
that code.
So the only code that you have to
provide
is the map function and the reduce
function that are particular for doing
one of these tasks.
And maybe, you know, some tuning
parameters saying things like how many
machines to use. And perhaps a little
bit of code saying where to find the
input and where to store the output.
And then the framework will handle the
rest for you.
Questions about any of this so far?
All right.
Well, I think it's about time to take
our break.
So, I'll put up our quiz question.
All right.
So, take a break, rest your eyes,
and I'll see you at 4:31.
I'm going to resume in about 2 minutes.
All right, welcome back.
So, let's do another example.
Let's look at word count cuz that's the
one that uh
is discussed in the paper. So, let's
let's uh draw another diagram and
let's see if we can see what the word
count example would look like.
So, let's say one more time that we have
three map workers.
And once again, let's say that we have a
whole bunch of documents
that are split up among all of these map
workers.
So, remember again that the the whole
point of using something like MapReduce
is when you have way more data
uh than will fit on a single machine.
So,
there's really no way to avoid having
your data set split among all these
different machines. But, as we'll see,
they can each do their computation
independently, so it's not a problem.
So, you've got a bunch of documents. We
could even say they're exactly the same
documents as before.
So,
maybe machine one has the quick brown
fox.
Maybe we'll make this more interesting.
So, maybe machine two says
my
fox
is cute.
Machine three says
my dog is cute.
And we're trying to do a word count to
figure out uh
how many occurrences there are of of all
the words in all the documents.
So,
what do the map workers have to do?
Well,
they're going to iterate over all the
words
that are in the document
and they're going to emit
these intermediate key-value pairs
one for every word. So, maybe this whole
sentence here is, you know, the quick
brown fox jumps over the lazy dog.
So, if we're just going through here and
emitting key-value pairs as we go along,
then it would look something like this.
We'd have like the
one
quick
brown
one etc. etc.
the
one lazy
one
dog
one.
So, those are all the intermediate
key-value pairs
uh generated and written locally on
machine one.
Is there any sort of optimization that
this machine could do at this stage,
assuming that what we want to do is a
word count? We eventually want to know
all the We want to We want a count of
all the occurrences of every word.
Is there anything that machine one can
do at this stage that would help
carry out that computation?
That's right. Yeah, it could do a little
bit of reduction work locally.
Right? Cuz these two pairs here,
they're both the key the. So, it could
combine those together, right? It could
could just say two here.
So, that's kind of nice, right? Machine
one can help a little bit with the
overall process
um
of doing the word count. It can do a
little bit of the computation that's
that's possible to do locally. Now,
that's not the whole job, right? Because
notice that, you know, machine three has
an occurrence of dog, right? And machine
one knows nothing about machine three's
occurrence of dog, nor should it, right?
At this phase of the computation,
machine one has no idea what's going on
over here on machine three, and it
shouldn't have to. But, it can do a
little bit locally. And so,
it it does.
So,
does anybody recall what that's called
uh in the MapReduce paper when you do a
little bit of this reduce work locally?
That's right. Yeah, it's called a
combined function.
So, the map workers can run the map
function.
And they can also do the combine.
And you can think of the combine as
being
a little tiny version of reduce that you
do locally to try to get that work out
of the way
and take a little bit of the work off of
the reduce workers' plate.
Just as much as you can.
Not anything that would require
communication with another machine.
All right. So, let's once again pretend
that we have two reduce workers.
In order to get the data onto the reduce
workers, we have to do our shuffle
phase, and this is the phase where all
of the map workers have to talk to all
of the reduce workers.
And so,
I believe the way that these arrows get
drawn in the diagram in the in the
MapReduce paper
uh
is the opposite of the way that I I drew
them.
Um Oh, no. Looking back at the paper, it
is the same as I drew them. So, you
could either think of it as,
you know, machine one writes to
uh reducer one and reducer two, and
machine two writes to R1 and R2, and M3
writes to R1 and R2, or you can think of
it as R1 reads from all of these, and R2
reads from all of these. So, whether you
think of it as a read or a write, um
that's kind of
not so important. The point is the data
has to get from one or the other. They
call it a read in the paper.
Um
So, R1 reads from all of these.
So, it is R2.
So, we've got our map phase.
We've got our shuffle.
And data ends up over here
partitioned by key.
So, maybe R1 ended up with
the
and then it ended up with
dog here.
And then it also ended up with this
key-value pair that had dog.
Maybe this one got my.
So, there's two of those.
Maybe fox
ended up here.
And so on. So, I won't bother writing
them all out. Let's say cute ended up
here as well.
And now all that's left is for the
reduce workers to do their job. So,
what is the reduce workers' job consist
of in this example?
It's pretty simple. Just has to take any
matching
uh
keys and then add those numbers
together, right?
So, dog one and dog one are going to get
combined into dog two.
Likewise here for my and cute.
And then all of that data is going to
get written onto the distributed file
system,
which is GFS or what have you.
This is the reduce phase.
And that would be a distributed word
count.
And in this one we were able to take
advantage of this notion of a combined
function
by doing a little bit of the reduce
computation over here. Now, if we hadn't
done that, would it be okay?
Yeah, it would still be fine if we had
just sent those pairs the one
the one over here to R1, then they would
still the then they would still be
computed over here and it would be fine.
But M1 is trying to save sending a
little bit of data over the network. And
so,
depending on the data, you can sometimes
save a lot of bandwidth by doing some of
the work over here on the mappers
using the combined function.
It's nice when you're able to do that.
Questions about any of this?
All right, here's a question for you.
Last week
we talked about sharding, right? We
talked about ways to shard data. And one
of the things we talked about
was that
if you wanted to shard data on a some
number of nodes, then one way to do
that,
right, was to take the hash of the key
and then do mod n, right? Where n is the
number of machines that you're you're
trying to shard onto.
But then we said that there was a
problem with doing it that way. What did
we say the problem was with this hash of
key mod n
sharding approach last time?
Right, when a node goes down. Yeah, or
in general, whenever the number of nodes
changes. And why does that cause a
problem?
Well, it means that if if this number
changes, right?
This hash of key mod n
tells you where a particular piece of
data is supposed to end up, right? But
this means if the number changes here,
then some of your data is going to end
up in a new place. So, all or almost all
of your data would end up having to move
around.
Much more of the data than it should
really be necessary to move around.
And why would n change? Well, it could
change if you decide to add a node,
right? If you you might decide you need
more nodes to sort store more data or
handle more throughput.
And why would n get smaller? Well, nodes
could die.
So, instead of doing this hash of key
mod n thing, we suggested using
consistent hashing.
So, organizing the nodes in a way where
we can think of them as being in a ring
and every node gets hashed to a
particular spot on the ring and it's
that the the node is responsible for the
keys that are in a particular range that
kind of corresponds to a particular
slice of that ring.
When nodes join or leave, it's only the
immediate neighbor on the ring that ends
up being affected. So, that's all great.
We talked about that. But then here we
are reading the MapReduce paper
and what does it do to suggest splitting
up these intermediate key-value pairs
onto the reduce workers? Well, it
suggests exactly this, hash of key mod
n, where n is the number of reduce
workers.
So, my question for you is
why is this okay?
They're suggesting doing this very thing
that we said last time was maybe not
such a good idea because of this idea
that the number of machines might
change.
But they're saying to do this in the
MapReduce paper.
Why do you think this is okay to do in
the setting of MapReduce?
It's kind of food for thought.
What do you think?
Yeah, okay. So, one thing in chat is
okay, maybe because this operation
happens all at once, you rehash every
time you MapReduce. Well,
yeah, so certainly when we're doing
MapReduce, I think maybe what you mean
by all at once is that when you do a
MapReduce,
you're expected to have all the data to
begin with, right? You're expected to
have all of this raw data.
So, you know how much raw data you have
to work with, right?
And you have to make some choices up
front about how many map workers, how
many reduce workers you want to work
with. I think the MapReduce framework
will choose certain defaults for you,
but you can put in certain choices
yourself as well. So,
that number is kind of set up front,
right? When you do when you start the
MapReduce computation, that number
changes.
And there's not any real facility in the
MapReduce computation for saying, oh,
we're going to add a new node now,
right? Because
you shouldn't need to because you
already know how much data you're
working with. It's not an online system
like Dynamo is. With Dynamo,
you're serving client requests. It's an
online system and all of a sudden you
could start getting more requests than
you were expecting and then you might
think, oh, well, we'd better add a new
node to the system.
Whereas with MapReduce,
for a given MapReduce job, you should
know how much data you're working with
to begin with. So,
you should have some sense of how many
reduce workers you need.
So, I think that's why
it isn't necessary to to have that
number
of reduce workers be flexible during a
given MapReduce job.
So, with consistent hashing and things
like that, we do it because we always
have to be responding to client
requests.
And whether or not a node dies, right?
Or uh regardless of what happens,
whether or not we're getting a whole
bunch of requests, we have to we have to
stay flexible. So, it's worth the
trouble when you're building an online
system like that
to make adding or losing nodes as
non-disruptive as possible.
But with MapReduce, you're not serving
client requests. Nobody's going to come
along in the middle of the MapReduce
computation and say, oh, here's another
piece of input data that you have to
handle. There's an assumption that at
the time you begin the computation, you
already have all the input data that
you're ever going to be operating on in
that computation. So, the framework can
make an a fair a fairly informed
decision up front about how many map
workers, how many reduce workers it
needs.
Um so, you the programmer um but
actually the framework decides for you,
I think, how many map workers it needs.
And you are expected to make a decision
about how many reduce workers you need.
Maybe you picked too small of a number
and then your job might take longer than
you like.
Oh, too bad. Better luck next time.
But um but you're expected to make an
informed choice about how many reduce
workers you need.
So, the assumption is that since you
have all the input data to begin with,
then you won't have to add more map
workers or more reduce workers in the
middle of that particular MapReduce job.
So, it's very different from something
like Dynamo, right? Where you might be
adding more nodes dynamically to improve
your throughput or just to store more
data. That's kind of not a thing in
MapReduce.
Okay, but what about if a node crashes?
What about when MapReduce workers crash?
How does the framework handle that?
Uh Somebody already mentioned in chat.
Yeah. So, one piece of the picture the
really important piece of MapReduce that
we actually didn't include here
is that there's
another machine involved that's called
the master.
So, I'll draw it up in the corner here.
So, the master is responsible for
assigning out tasks to all of these
workers, all the map uh the map workers
and the reduce workers. And its job is
to
ping them periodically
to see if they're still alive.
And if it doesn't hear back within some
given amount of time, then it's going to
assume that the the worker has failed.
So, the master knows what tasks are
assigned where. It knows who's a map
worker, who's a reduce worker.
And if it sees that a worker has failed
by not getting a response, then it can
take the task that it was working on,
reset its knowledge of that task, say,
"Okay, that task is unfinished." And it
can assign some other worker to it.
So, there's a little bit of discussion
of this in the paper.
If a map worker fails, let's look at map
workers for a second.
Let's say that one of the map worker
fails. Let's say that this one fails.
What happens then?
Do you have to start that work over from
the beginning?
Let's say that it's
not only does it fail, but let's let's
say its disk gets trashed.
Well,
remember this is just a local write.
When this map worker is
producing its intermediate key-value
pairs. So, it's not storing this data
anywhere on GFS or anything like that.
It's just storing its data locally. So,
if it dies, that data is no longer
accessible.
So, that work really does have to be
redone if one of these map worker dies.
Is that a good choice? Well, this is a
choice that uh trade-off that they make
in the design of MapReduce. They could
have stored all this intermediate data
on GFS.
And then it would be still available
even if that map worker died. But then
that would take more time than storing
it locally, right? So, they considered
the pros and cons, and they decided that
they would rather store data locally and
occasionally pay the cost of having to
redo a computation
than store it on GFS and not have to pay
that um recomputation cost, but have to
pay this uh this additional cost of
storing on GFS, right?
So, distributed systems is the thing
thing I say all the time, right?
Distributed systems are full of
trade-offs like this.
And one of the hallmarks of MapReduce is
that they often make the choice where
they would prefer to redo computation
if there's a failure
than pay the extra cost of of um
of storing the data somewhere else.
That's how they approach fault
tolerance.
Uh so, there's a question in chat about
what replaced MapReduce at Google. Well,
uh first of all, um
MapReduce is still used at Google. So,
it's not completely gone.
Um
and the systems that replaced MapReduce
are
uh
still spiritually similar to what we're
talking about here. So, the essence of
what I'm talking about here,
whether it's whether or not it's still
faithful to
uh
to what actually is is is um the
specifics of what's being used,
the spirit is the same. So, the general
idea of of having this uh distributed
data processing system, some things
about um
uh
the design might be different, some
things about the framework might be
different, but
it's it's not necessarily
uh I mean, I I think this is still worth
studying, right? Because
I think um
the key ideas are are have have changed
remarkably little. I do think that it's
worth looking at streaming systems if
you're interested in kind of like the
future of this sort of thing. Because
one thing that you might want to ask is
well, what if you're doing this word
count and then one more document comes
along, right?
I would rather
add the results of doing the word count
on that one new document and do it
incrementally rather than having to do
the whole MapReduce job over again,
right?
So, a streaming system can support that
kind of thing. It can support data that
arrives in a streaming incremental
fashion and not having to recompute
everything when you receive some new
data. So,
streaming systems are worth looking
into.
Um
and hopefully you can you can kind of
get a sense of why.
And by streaming systems, I just mean
systems that are kind of like MapReduce
in that they compute on large amounts of
um
of of input data and process it to
produce derived data, but are also able
to receive new data in an incremental
fashion and process it in an incremental
fashion without having to redo all the
previous computation.
All right, we're out of time for today.
Next time we're going to talk about a
little bit more MapReduce stuff.
So, have a good weekend. Enjoy your
holiday weekend.
And I will see you on Tuesday.